if you want to be like Steve Jobs today
I'm going to give you three ways to get
started hi I'm Evan Carmichael
I believe in entrepreneurs and today I
mention a question for one of my YouTube
subscribers love you guys lacks wrote in
to say hi Evan this is LOX a regular
review your videos love the belief
videos never stop doing that sir
thank you lacks I'm a college student
and I always wanted to be an
entrepreneur like Steve Jobs my idol but
I'm confused on how to start can you
help me thanks in advance LOX this is a
fantastic question I'm a huge Steve Jobs
fan myself and today I'm going to give
you the three ways for how you can start
following his footsteps
number one is follow your passion more
than anything else a thing that Steve
Jobs was great at was following his
passion whatever he was interested in no
matter how crazy it was no matter how
the rest of the world would see it he
would go for it even if everybody else
thought he was crazy it's easy to follow
your passion and everybody supporting
you and telling you to go for it it's
really hard to do it when nobody is
supporting you and feels like the whole
world is against you so as an example
when Steve Jobs was in university he
didn't like it he wasn't feeling the
classes he didn't feel that it was for
him even though he was on the path to a
stable normal career like everybody else
so he dropped out of his classes to drop
in on calligraphy classes to learn about
writing and fonts and people thought he
was crazy why are you going to learn
about writing and fonts what possible
good is this ever going to do for you
and the boldness and the courage came
from not knowing how it was going to
work out Steve Jobs didn't know how that
class was going to help him he only
signed up for because he was interested
in it and he was following his passion
it was only years later that when the
first Mac came out it was the font and
the beautiful typography that really
helped the computer stand out against
every other computer on the market when
he first got into computers everybody
thought he was nuts nobody needed a
personal computer everybody thought it
was only for the big guys the idea that
everybody would have the computer in
their home was ridiculous it would get
you laughed out of a room but Steve Jobs
didn't care he was following his passion
and trusted that it would work out so if
you want to be like Steve Jobs have
the guts and the boldness to follow your
true passion
number two is partner up Steve Jobs
never did everything himself
he always had talented people around him
to help him build his dream at the very
start it was Steve Wozniak who was a
technical genius and brains behind the
early Mac computers and his Apple group
Steve Jobs continued to surround himself
with smart talented people who are the
top of their field who wanted to do
something important stop trying to do
everything yourself and partner up with
the team and individuals who can help
get you to your dream faster and number
three is set high standards Steve Jobs
was insanely detail-oriented and wanted
everything he created to be awesome you
have to create high standards not just
in your business but also in your life
what are things that you are no longer
willing to accept to help you get to the
next level Steve Jobs had high standards
about the suppliers that he work with
with the things that were going into the
computers with the people that he hired
for his team everything had to meet
insanely high standards if you want your
life to be up here but your own personal
standards are way down here there's no
way to bridge that gap until you raise
the standards of what you are now no
longer willing to accept here's a fine
clip from a Nike CEO where when he first
got his job
he asked Steve Jobs for some advice and
Jobs told him to stop selling crap and
to raise their standards
I mentioned last night when we were
having dinner that when you first got
the job as CEO you got a call from Steve
Jobs and he offered you some advice well
he didn't call to offer me advice but we
had worked together on a Nike Apple
collaboration called Nike plus so we
took what Apple knows what Nike knows
you know brought a new technology to the
market anyway long story short he said
hey congratulations it's great you're
going to do a great job I said well do
you have any advice and he said no no
you're great and then there's a pause
and it goes well I do have some advice
because Nike makes some of the best
product in the world
I mean product that you lust after
absolutely beautiful stunning product
but you also make a lot of crap we said
just get rid of the crappy stuff and
focus on the good stuff and then I
expected a little pause and a laugh but
there was there was a pause but no laugh
at the end and he was absolutely right
so remember follow your passion partner
up and set high standards and of course
believe thank you guys so much for
watching if you like this video I'd love
to hear we have to say in the comments
I'd love to know what your thoughts are
on Steve Jobs and how he may have
influenced you if you want to share your
story in the comments below if you liked
this video you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the newsletter
into the channel thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon